they came in there thousands to remember
what they did five years ago and how
much more they have yet to achieve
several rallies have been planned over
the next few days this was marking the
launch of the pro-democracy umbrella
movement in 2014 it petered out after 79
days they're determined that's not going
to happen again what makes you think
this one might succeed
I am optimistic with the future
especially I think how even I'm not a
leader standing the forefront but with
the spontaneous and organic and
self-initiative action it's just that
our movement go forward but tensions are
high a man flying a Chinese flag was set
upon by protesters in Hong Kong now
different views are likely to end in
blood being spilled
[Applause]
the rally ended early as a few meters
away protesters tried to break into the
central government offices rocks were
logged at the government buildings
followed by petrol bombers this weekend
was always going to be testing hundreds
of police are guarding the Hong Kong
authorities officers and they warned
they're prepared to use force to quell
the disturbances
they've come armed with their sponge
ball rifles and their what they call
their beanbag rifles which can they're
meant to be less lethal I think is how
they describe them but they can do a
fair amount of damage with the
demonstrators trying to force their way
in it didn't take long for the police to
move into action firing multiple rounds
of tear gas and spraying water cannon
including using plumes of blue dye to
try to semi-permanently mark the
protestors it is difficult to remove and
causes a burning sensation on the skin
prompting criticism from human rights
activists but with the 70th anniversary
of communist rule in China only days
away many of the protesters were openly
telling each other to save themselves
for October the first much of Kong
Kong's National Day celebrations have
been scaled back because of fears of
violence the city is bracing itself for
days of unrest
Alex Crawford Sky News Hong Kong